[Music]
can we chat real estate for like a quick
second before we get to the phones sure
okay so he just said on the last call
you know that things are kind of slowing
down i think people were kind of feeling
that even in nashville a little bit it's
not like insane like it was six months
ago
and i've heard you say how the housing
prices
will probably not dip
down right like 08 right so the
difference
or what is the difference in the market
from 08 to now because people i've heard
people say i'm going to wait until the
prices go back down
and they're not as red hot to buy today
because the prices are crazy to buy a
house right now
but they won't go back
your prediction if you had a crystal
ball would that they're not going to go
back is it because the 08 crash had to
do around
all
the the borrowing from mortgages and
security back loans all of that is it
because that recession was fueled by the
real estate market that it went down and
this is different
or what's the what's the reason because
i hear that question constantly of like
oh people think that that the housing
prices are going to go back down
it's like it's not always
as simple as supply and demand
but it almost always is
now what causes the supply
shortage and the demand increase or the
demand to be down and the supply to go
up
is varying things and you can start
looking at that but the the root issue
of what drives house prices almost
always is supply and demand
uh and that's true so you know the the
old joke of in an appraisal class you
know i was an appraisal class give me an
old joke of the old appraisal class
i don't know much
real estate has one joke and this is it
what you know what determines the price
of real estate location location and
location
yeah but not really because
so in other words you could take a
concrete block house that's a thousand
square foot and put it in the rich into
town
and it'll bring a whole lot more than a
really nice house in the dumpy
crime ridden horrible into town right
okay so it's not the quality of the
house it's not the thing it's not the
mortgage rates it's it's where the
stinking thing sits
okay the people perceive that why does
that affect it well because more people
want it's more desirable to live over
there more people chasing that piece of
dirt then chase the dirt over in the
other town yeah and so it is supply
versus demand ultimately now interest
rates affect that when interest rates go
up guess what fewer buyers yep so the
demand goes down thus prices are going
to soften
or not be as cray-cray as they have been
right and that's what we're seeing right
now
uh if supply can go up even if rate
interest rates go up if supply went up
faster if we could double the amount of
houses on the market by snapping our
fingers and interest rates went to six
percent which they are okay uh or five
and some change whatever right uh then
you would see uh demand you know you'd
still see because there's 10 houses for
every two buyers instead of two houses
for every 10 buyers
that's the problem is that we're always
facing right is the supply demand thing
now in 2008 what happened was there was
a tremendous over
supply
because they foreclosures went
everywhere
and the market just froze
nobody was buying houses had nothing to
do with the economy really had nothing
to do with interest rates it had to do
with there was a real estate panic and
people quit buying and there's this huge
supply
we dumped a bazillion properties on the
market and all the buyers are standing
on the sidelines looking at it
so almost no demand huge supply so you
see one time in the last hundred years
that real estate prices actually went
down
and that was 2008 but that was huge
supply almost no demand now what do we
got right now
shortage of houses
and the buyers are calming down because
interest rates are going up and supply
is catching up slowly
because some of the new housing stuff's
starting to come back on labor shortage
uh is starting to a little bit and be
alleviated some of the biden bucks are
running out people are actually having
to go back to work
the um
uh uh
lumber prices have stabilized so new
housing is coming on the market again
at a better rate than it was say a year
and a half ago so we got a little bit of
supply up and a little bit of demand
down and so we've got a softening in the
rate of increase of price but you're not
going to see prices go down because
you're not going to see the demand
versus the supply shift enough to cause
prices to go down okay that's great
that's what i'm that's what i keep
looking at and it's not it's really nice
yeah it's but it is the old appraisal
class we all just got to go through
america there you go
by the old by the old guy but that's
what i wanted to know though because we
keep because i you know i mean it's
still even within our friend group it's
like people are talking about okay well
buying in this and we want to do this we
got to hold off here and you know and
you hear the rumblings of we're just
going to wait 12 months until prices go
back down but here's the reason the
economy and
the stock market and real estate is so
interesting
because it really is at the end of the
day psychology
is what are the buyers going to do
what are people going to are they going
to act how they going to react
and you know if everybody thinks
facebook's going to be a big deal you
know what facebook stock goes up if
everybody thinks apple is the second
coming of jesus then apple stock is i
mean apple has more money than egypt
literally it's crazy and so you know uh
this kind of stuff right but but what it
amounts to is it's perception
people believe it and they make it so
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy out
there in the economy all the time and so
if enough people believe that the market
is wonderful and crazy and white hot
then they go behave like that and a an
asking price on a piece of real estate
is no lo is no longer an asking price
it's a suggested starting point
for the auction
and so because because the cray-cray
it's all the psychology on it and so but
if everybody suddenly went you know what
i'm gonna chill
boom you would you would freeze these
prices like a deer in the headlight and
so we see that like if you go all the
way back to when i was a kid like 1982
okay
and carter
interest rates fixed rates for mortgages
went to 18
well guess what
no demand
but house prices still didn't go down
much yeah i mean they did it was just
for a little bit but you couldn't give a
house away i mean if you had to sell a
house it was probably going to be maybe
a little bit of a discount
but they still sat there and then
stinking prices came down to where i'm
24 years old selling houses in 1984
at 14 fixed rates that year they
announced this brand new type of
mortgage called the adjustable rate
mortgage
and a r m
in 1984 you could get for 12 where your
fixed rate was 14
and people are lined up around the block
why because all those people that didn't
buy for the three years prior to that
because it was 18 and 17 and 16
all of them came into the market in one
year
boom market took off went crazy at 14
interest rates yeah that's nuts that's
nuts but it's all supply demand it and
underlying it now different things cause
the supply to be up or down yep the
demand to be up or down but always be
looking for that that's gonna tell you
what's gonna happen with the market